fake talking cat just what we need
around here
Salem from Sabrina the Teenage Witch
graced our screens in the 90s
Salem guard my door so Jenny doesn't go
anywhere okay hey dogs guard cats watch
and judge for the actor behind the sass
playing the role of a puppet suited him
just fine puppets can get away with
murder
don't ever do a scene with him no one's
looking at you I'm having a bad day hi
I'm Nick McCoy and I'm best known
probably as the voice of Salem the
talking cat on Sabrina the Teenage Witch
Salem was a very frustrated guy who
tried to take over the world his
punishment was they turned him into a
cat for a hundred years
there was a lovely bitterness to the
character that I leaned into hard Salem
the only one who understands me yeah but
it doesn't mean that I care you know I
was in the writers room on that show too
so I could pitch my own jokes you should
take your temperature under the tongue
under the time I was on set doing the
voice live first four years took a
village to do that cat because then you
have animal trainers on a multitude of
live cats and there was a remarkable
crew of puppeteers our head puppeteer
was Tom found is really gifted he ran
the mouth and we had Maury who wrote the
body and she spent her days and darkness
jammed into that kitchen island counter
you know just working that body it was a
real team effort but nick is more than
just a cat voice it was also the voice
of Norbert don't mess with the bull my
friend you'll get the horns the big
older brother I'm the Nickelodeon
cartoon angry beavers I've been a writer
producer on a bunch of other shows my
king of queens I also wrote the paul
blart mall cop movies with my pal Kevin
James
and he's been in front of the camera -
on some well-known shows like Seinfeld
[Music]
That 70's Show and this IOL ad thanks to
America Online I'm really just goofing
off this is back during my trying to
make my Christmas actor face you did
some deep dig there huh so it's like
just you and me want to do each other's
hair I love cats I've had cats my whole
life up until very recently we had a cat
named Salem a little black cat and we
rescued for 16 years I tried to make
friends with my namesake wasn't in the
cards up hated my gods